foreign
I am fluent in the language of BS
otherwise known as business speak or
depending on your point of view
what is BS or business speak business
speak is the language we use on the job
and only on the job to describe and
Define things for instance at home I
might say to my son it's time to go are
you ready
while at work I'm more likely to say to
a colleague is it scalable you can give
me a baseline ETA on departure
we need to leave ASAP
right
I was first introduced to the language
of BS through my wife she's a chief
marketing officer for a global
consulting firm and one day a few years
back at home she was doing a conference
call on speaker and she started to use
the language of BS I had never heard
this woman speak this language before
I was concerned she was a spy
she used terms like boil the ocean tiger
team SWOT analysis foreign
afterwards she translated those terms to
me in in phrases that a human being can
actually understand
and I did what every good partner does
in a solid marriage
I made fun of that word
relentlessly
I may not make as much money as my
wife's colleagues I certainly don't have
the degrees they do but I know a messed
up thing when I hear it
and I devoted years of my life to
compiling researching and then writing a
BS dictionary
yes thank you thank you
I can now tell my kids that an
auditorium full of people applauded me
for all this worthless work I did over
the last few years
so in the words of BS with this
expertise I say to you that my
presentation to you today
the CTA of this DIY tedx talk if you
will
is a USP on the rise of BS in our wiffum
world
and how we can make this Intel less
scalable during the fourth Industrial
Revolution
if you don't understand what I've just
said that's okay you don't speak BS
if you do understand what I've just said
God help you
yes
[Music]
so let me give it another shot I'll
translate that in more common words the
call to action of my presentation to you
is to make the point that business speak
is on the rise in our globalized economy
but there are simple things we can all
do in our day-to-day jobs with that
language to take the out of BS
so what I present to you is three ways
of how to take the BS out of business
speak
first you've been sitting for a while so
let me pull the room I'm going to get
your feet working here
I want you to stomp your feet on
honestly stomp your feet if you know
what the BS term ebitda means
nice okay maybe you've got some CEOs
some accountants in the room never know
okay now stomp your feet if you know
what earnings before interest tax
depreciation and amortization means
a little bit more to be honest I'm sure
some of you with amortization were like
I don't know if I should stop
right okay now stomp your feet if you
know what income is before applying
accounting and tax write-offs to it
it's close call but I'm going to make a
judgment call here the loudest stomping
in this theater got to the last
definition of the same thing
ebitda is basically income before you
apply accounting tax write-offs to it
and notice that the most common language
got the biggest agreement from this
audience
but here's the problem with BS it is not
a common language
business speak is the language of the
elite
not surprisingly when my co-author and I
Tim Ito researched about 300
business-speak terms for this dictionary
one of the reoccurring themes is the
people who created this language and
speak it most fluently a large majority
of them are people who look like me
a bunch of white guys
I'd say that's not surprisingly because
I want you to think the first and second
Industrial Revolution when white guys
like John D Rockefeller and Andrew
Carnegie ruled the business world and
it's true today when research shows that
90 percent
of all worldwide Fortune 500 company
CEOs are white guys still
here's the takeaway for you in the room
if you want to hang with today's wild
white male tycoons Bill Gates Elon Musk
Jeff Bezos Warren Buffett it would
benefit you to get very Adept and able
to speak BS
but there's a drawback to that approach
I have a friend Emily who works at a
theater company in the United States
this theater company does corporate
entertainment keynote speeches for
conferences
she started her job a few years ago and
had her first big meeting to try to make
a sale it was with a big Oil Company in
Dallas and across the boardroom from her
were five old white guys
and Emily noticed very early on that
they did something very interesting with
their language choices
they started to use BS words that they
knew she didn't know
now why would they do that
three possible reasons I talked to Emily
we've worked out some theories
one these guys didn't know any better
and Economist Robin Hogarth had coined
the term the curse of knowledge to
describe this phenomenon it may be
simply that they're so expert at their
language they they don't appreciate
anymore what it's like to not know these
things and they just spoke off the top
of their head
as a corporate consultant for public
speaking the companies that I work for
the reason I give them this advice is
because of that phenomenon I will tell
them if you have a lot of BS in your
four walls and it could be unique just
to your company or it's just general
acronyms and things you use in the
business world and you have a new
employee maybe give them a directory of
some of these terms
so instead of walking into a meeting and
smiling and nodding and then frantically
Googling afterwards what the hell does
ebitda mean
that they'll know
second reason why these five oil
Executives possibly handled Emily this
way
they wanted to parse out from her how
much they knew how much she knew about
the business
instead of asking her directly excuse me
Emily can you tell me how much
experience you have in our industry and
let's go from there
they used BS as a way to keep Emily and
them apart rather than bring them
together
third possible reason these oil
Executives handled it that way they were
just jerks
and Emily thinks that's the answer
because shortly after her initial
conversation she brought in a more
senior male colleague lo and behold the
five oil Executives warm up
they cut out the BS and a deal is struck
shortly thereafter
so that's something for us to think
about as our first takeaway of how to
take the BS out of business speak
use BS to be inclusive and not exclusive
in other words
don't be a jerk
if you can explain something in common
language
that's a victory
the edit is the genius
not spouting off all these big words
which brings me to my second takeaway of
how to take BS out of business speak
let's get those feet stomping again
how many of you stomp your feet if you
know what the word de minimis means
okay good I don't feel so alone because
I was alike a lot of you did not stomp
your feet a few years back
as was mentioned in my intro I used to
work for The Daily Show with John
Stewart for those of you don't know it
is a comedy show that's naturally
broadcast in America that satirized the
news of the day and I was interviewing
an accountant about a tax issue that he
used the word de minimis to describe
and I interrupted him right there and I
said to men what what the f does that
mean
and he said it means small immaterial
it's insignificant
to which I said well why didn't you just
say that
and he said in a moment of honesty he
said uh
just thought it sounded good
and the reality is it does sound it's
kind of a cool word de minimis and I'm
guilty of doing it too especially in a
business meeting where I'm unsure of my
status in that room I may use ebitda
right just to show hey I can hang I can
hang
but here's the thing about communication
you know what's really cool about good
communication especially in the business
world
is when you can express fresh ideas
without using stale business cliches
and big words that people in the room
don't really understand
so that's my second way to take the BS
out of business language
for you
to drive this home uh even further
a lady that I worked with in my
corporate work works for a big American
company one of the biggest companies in
American if not the world
she works for bosses that use a ton of
business cliches so much so to keep
herself sane she told me she created
homemade BS Bingo cards
replace the numbers in the Bingo cards
with the phrases that they used over and
over again so when they turned up the BS
in a conference call she tuned out and
tried to play Bingo
B think outside the box I change agent
and Paradigm Shift right
so these are things for us to think
about
that if we're using BS a lot of it in
our business speak it may be like
Shakespeare said Sound and Fury
signifying nothing
which brings me to my final takeaway of
how to take BS out of business speak
let's stick with Shakespeare Shakespeare
has given us some great BS speak and
stuff that allows itself to exist
outside of business speak in the English
language
wild goose chase think about this kind
of a weird reference
that's from Shakespeare break the ice in
a pickle
all from Shakespeare the good news is
when we hear references like this from
Shakespeare a lot of us in the world at
least have a little bit of an experience
with Shakespeare and we have context
clues we can figure it out
but I want you to think of other
cultural touch points that aren't as
common as Shakespeare I'm going to put
up some phrases that are commonly used
in America
and if you know it's common origin just
yell it out if you're wrong it's okay
we'll edit it out of the video
swing for the fences out of left field
rain check off base pinch hitter
right off the bat anybody know
baseball there you go
I'm gonna put up another list of phrases
again you tell me what the common origin
is
blind leading the blind
by the skin of your teeth fly in the
ointment writing is on the wall
the Bible
I I suppose you have a Bible you're
reading scripture between speakers
like good Christian okay yeah you're
right no rest for the wicked also comes
from the Bible
here's my point
think of the global economy now
and the majority of people on this Earth
don't have daily experience with
American baseball and they don't read
the Bible
but you're sitting in a business meeting
saying we have no we have no time no
rest for the wicked
the writing is on the wall
do they know what you're talking about
clap your hands if you've ever heard the
American phrase drinking the Kool-Aid
great anybody who clapped their hands
what does it mean
laughs
it's it
what's that
we'll get there we'll get there
you've read my script you know where I'm
going
what does writing the cool writing or
drinking the Kool-Aid what does that
mean
succumbing to peer pressure it's kind of
in there it's it's it's accepting
something without question just sort of
like I did with you guys and saying
stomp your feet this is like a shirt or
whatever
right
yes and to the balcony's response here's
the origin story of drinking the
Kool-Aid and the reason why I bring this
up is because it's important to know the
origin story of some of our BS
Jim Jones this cult leader he's adorable
1978 he has a great idea all of his
hundreds of followers he's going to give
them a delicious drink
that's wonderful Jim Jones to do he
flavors it with something called flavor
Which is popular at the time it's later
confused in history with more popular
flavored drink in America called
Kool-Aid
but Jim made a bad mistake with that
Kool-Aid man he laced it with cyanide
hundreds of followers drink the cyanide
and die
1978 that's the origin story of drinking
the Kool-Aid
the reason I bring that up is because a
European audience you're like what is
Kool-Aid
also if you're born Beyond 1978 you may
not even know what this is who is this
guy what are you talking about mass
suicide a cult with Kool-Aid
drinking the Kool-Aid and there are
other BS phrases that fall in this
category we've lost the origin story it
gets muddied think of Ted Talk the
internet if you type who founded Ted or
where did Ted come from it's a person on
the internet
it's technology entertainment design
that's what Ted Talks stands for think
of the BS phrase piggyback you ever seen
two pigs with one Pig on on its back
I haven't either here's why because the
origin story of this phrase is actually
pick back or pick pack
but it was so commonly misstated as
piggyback that that mispronunciation
which mispronunciation was adopted and
now it means piggyback
and pigs are like what the hell are you
talking about
and there are lots more like this
because we're up against lunch I won't
bore you with an origin story it's a
true one it's horrible about the BS
phrase blowing smoke up your ass
for example but I won't go there
here's the uh takeaway out of all of
this is that BS terms can get lost in
translation and I want you to think of
some of your own cultural BS that we use
around the world for example in America
if a company is without money you might
say it's broke in Italy you would say
it's in the green in Spain you would say
it's without white right in America if
you're doing a very easy task you might
say it was a piece of cake in New
Zealand you say Bob's your uncle right
if you have a very hard task that will
never happen in America you would
probably say oh it'll happen when pigs
fly
in the Netherlands a Dutch worker would
say when the Cavs dance on the ice
and in Russia they would say when a
crayfish whistles from The Mountaintop
means the same thing
in Japan if you were doing a work task
and you need help you're desperate for
anybody you may say I'll adopt cat paws
in America if you were given a task that
is one day over a long-term project and
man you're just getting started you may
say that it's a drop in the bucket in
China they have the same idea
communicated through the phrase of nine
cows and only one cow thread
so those are examples of cultural
differences with BS and I'd be remiss to
leave you for lunch without calling out
some of the the regional fondness for
food in your BS in the German language
think of yourself when you're in a
business meeting in Germany or in
Austria with the German language if you
want to add your two cents in America
you'd say two cents here you say I want
to add my mustard
okay and once you get that mustard you
want to be as clear as dumpling broth
about what you're trying to say right
you certainly don't want to come across
as somebody has tomatoes on their eyes
you know and the last thing you want to
do in that scenario is you don't want to
talk around the hot porch
okay which the equivalent of beating
around the bush with American BS
I've given you a lot of over a
short amount of time so I'm going to
wrap it up with a little BS language and
we'll recap here
in BS
what I am trying to say is disambiguate
the net net of this dog and pony show
for you thought leaders
and I'm going to call out the elephant
in the room
with the three takeaways here first
takeaway use BS to be inclusive not
exclusive
second takeaway is to make sure that you
express fresh ideas without stale
business cliches or big words that maybe
your audience doesn't really understand
and then finally appreciate that a lot
of our BS is Lost in Translation
depending on the audience
if we can all do this starting at
lunchtime
think of how little less there
would be in the world
and what a wonderful thing that would be
thank you very much
[Music]